[Music]
he goes way beyond the outline
responsibilities and duties of a bus
driver i mean that bus is like a family
these are my children these are my
community i love them all
[Music]
she's the administrative assistant to
the president administrative assistant
yeah
yeah
[Music]
and we're to care about each other and
we're going to love everybody right
i put time effort love care
understanding understanding each and
every one of those kids
[Music]
i'm hoping this t-shirt inspired her to
keep on writing books
my mom got divorced when i was only four
he's the father that i always wanted
in some ways i
just i wish my dad could have been like
that
[Music]
you still drive a bus
i don't drive a bus at this time i was
promoted you were promoted yes teaching
other bus drivers it was a great
opportunity for me to
show the enthusiasm that i had
with the kids and give it to someone
else sounds like a good job it does
sound like a good job are you still
talking to the kids that were on your
bus route yeah i go to the school
frequently and i see those kids those
kids are very very very dear to my heart
and he's going to the ninth grade now in
your opinion do you think that people
can make themselves feel enthusiastic
about something
you can't make this up because you know
what any job that you get you can find
some type of joy everybody can find
purpose in everything that they do